Salut ! Nous sommes en pleine semaine spéciale micro-expressions.
N'oubliez pas que dans la description il y a un lien vers une playlist qui regroupe l'ensemble des vidéos de cette semaine,
et celles que j'avais déjà faites précédemment sur les micro-expressions.
Il y a également un lien vers le livre de Paul Ekman ''Je sais que vous mentez'',
qui est un petit peu l'essence même de tout ce travail moderne sur la micro-expression depuis 1978.
Ouuuui c'est précis !
Après avoir parlé du dégoût, de la colère et de la surprise, aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu plus léger
puisqu'on va parler de la joie !
Mais également des UA, des Unités d'Action de Paul Ekman.
Générique !
La joie c'est peut-être l'émotion qu'on simule le plus socialement.
Pourtant il est très simple de différencier une vraie joie d'une joie simulée,
il y a UN signe ultime à connaître, mais avant ça parlons des signes majeurs de cette micro-expression.
Il y a les muscles de joues qui remontent, un peu comme ça mais en moins psychopathe quand même !
Les muscles autour des lèvres qui remontent en direction des yeux,
ce que l'on appelle dans le jargon, ''un sourire''.
Et le vrai signal complémentaire, c'est le sourire de Duchenne.
(effet cathédrale)  ''Le sourire de Duchenne''
ça claque hein dis comme ça?
ça claque, mais on sait toujours pas ce que c'est...
Ce sont les yeux qui se plissent au niveau des extérieurs, au niveau des petites rides.
Tu vois ça c'est pas des rides, c'est le sourire de Duchenne !
Il faut simplement analyser les rides autour des yeux, est ce qu'il y a toutes ces rides, tous ces plis autour des yeux ?
C'est un détail qui est imparable !
Voici 2 exemples que la BBC avait mis en ligne il y a quelques années, je vous laisse les regarder, voici le 1er :
Voici le 2e :
J'vais mettre 2 commentaires moi personnellement à cet effet,
Vous likez le commentaire que vous pensez être le bon et d'ici 1 ou 2 jours je donnerais la bonne réponse,
mais je pense que dans les pouces, la vraie réponse se dégagera et se verra d'elle-même.
L'apport qu'a fait Paul Ekman aux micro-expressions, est total !
Alors, oui je sais que lundi j'ai pris un raccourcit que le sujet qui était contradictoire avec ma toute première
vidéo sur les micro-expressions,
parce qu'il est pas réellement le premier à s'être penché sur la question.
Néanmoins, c'est lui qui en 1978 a publié les UA, les Unités d'Action.
Il a nommé un par un tous les muscles et le mouvement associé à ce muscle.
Un sorte de dictionnaire des différents mouvements des muscles faciaux, qu'il arrive lui à maîtriser un par un.
C'est d'ailleurs assez impressionnant !
En associant tous ces muscles entre eux, il a réussi à isoler 10 000 expressions faciales différentes,
Sur ces 10 000 expressions, y'en a 3 000 qui correspondent à un sens précis et les 7 000 autres sont plus des grimaces.
Et c'est de ces 3 000 expressions, qu'il a retiré les 7 expressions globales pour l'humanité toute entière,
qui sont les micro-expressions dont on parle nous cette semaine.
Une micro-expression d'une émotion est donc un ensemble de plusieurs muscles
puisqu'on peut retrouver le même muscle parfois dans des micro-expressions différentes:
on l'a vu avec la colère et le dégoût.
La notion d'ensemble est essentielle !
Pour le sourire simulé, n'oubliez pas qu'il peut cacher une peur ou une colère.
Le sourire est souvent utilisé comme un masque.
N'oubliez jamais de vérifier si la personne en face de vous qui sourit à ce que l'on appelle les yeux rieurs,
c'est aussi une autre manière d'appeler le sourire de Duchenne.
Au cours de cette semaine, tous les jours je vous ai proposé de vous concentrer sur les points clés d'un visage
et de les regarder toujours du coin de l'oeil en permanence.
Ainsi, quand les signaux bougeront durant un quart de seconde à peine,
vous y serez plus sensible.
Avant d'analyser il faut pouvoir détecter et c'est aussi le but de cette série de vidéos !
Pour continuer avec la joie, ayez conscience sur le visage de l'autre des lèvres :
pincements, lèvres qui remontent, s'entrouvrent, fais des sourires,
lèvres qui fais des trucs!
Sourcils en entiers, narines : dilatations et remontées,
les yeux : est ce qu'ils s'écarquillent?
Le menton, est ce qu'il remonte?
Et aujourd'hui on rajoute donc les joues.
On est toujours sur la même zone, sur ce même rectangle, sauf qu'on vient de l'élargir un tout petit peu.
On va dire qu'on surveille maintenant cette partie là du visage.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, si elle vous a plu,
n'oubliez pas de le faire savoir en laissant un pouce en l'air, et de vous abonner à la chaîne,
ça se passe ici - Attends je vais le refaire parce que maintenant j'utilise les nouvelles fiches de chez Youtube.
Vous avez vu ? Vous pouvez même le faire depuis un téléphone portable, ça marche vraiment de partout,
donc je vais me décaler là. N'oubliez pas de vous abonnez à la chaîne en cliquant ici ou ici,
puisque le mental vlog c'est 1 vidéo par jour pendant 1 an du 1er janvier au 31 décembre donc rdv demain à 17h. Ciao !